[Music]
we've covered a lot of big topics
tonight but there is one more thing i
would like to amber what's up derek uh
someone from the network asked if we
could do a real quick brand promo right
now yeah
uh they dropped off this bottle of
lotion and they said all you have to do
is just smile and put lotion on your
hands while they play a pre-recorded
audio
well i do love lotion all right
okay thanks derek no problem all right
let's do this
we are the makers of low chanel brand
lotion we really know our customers and
we're on a mission to tell every woman
you're beautiful on the inside and the
outside
even if that woman has an ugly secret an
ugly what
when you put on low chanel brand lotion
take a moment to remember you are
beautiful even if you don't wear socks
with shoes oh i don't
we think you're beautiful even if you
don't know how to do the electric slide
me too
or even if you didn't rsvp to jared's
wedding wait is this about me we think
you're beautiful even if you do that
thing where you reach for your wallet
slowly hoping one of your other friends
will pick up the check everyone does
that especially when you're out with
rebecca rebecca makes a lot of money low
chanel really knows our customers so hey
keep applying lotion sorry
low chanel brand lotion protects and
revitalizes your skin even if that skin
belongs to a woman with a terrible
secret i wouldn't call this liking socks
a terrible secret i'm talking about the
fact that you sleep with a michael b
jordan body pillow that's just so i can
practice kissing i'm talking about you
cheating on your driver's test hey if
they can't tell the difference between
me and my sister that's their fault i'm
talking about that hit and run i didn't
run away i drove okay you know what i am
done with this
did i say stop putting on lotion no
wait i thought that this was
pre-pre-recorded
it is but here at lo chanel we really
know our customers and every time you
put on low chanel we want you to
remember you are beautiful and we know
all of your ugliest secrets do i need to
call a lawyer you probably should
there's some shady stuff in your tax
returns amber who are you
we're low chanel and we told you
we really know our customers
[Music]
you